hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Hector we're rolling
right along still going kind of loopy
but that's besides the point now because
I haven't been able to find any damn
pills oh the access card is already in
there so do I need to spin this around
or is that access card no good my access
card don't work here
alrighty then I'll just keep freaking
out and do nothing
Boop I switch buttons I do things oh boy
it's Bryden I can see maybe this door
will open now because there's an access
card already in it
can I please can I please please pretty
please
ready ready please right apparently not
so I can't go back so there must be
something here
generators active glory work oh there's
a note here yeah my sessions weren't
going well and then they brought me down
here it's dirty and old
I'm afraid II do I haven't seen anyone
else
I hear them though screaming from the
other cells comforting trying to stay
strong I keep telling myself that I just
need to make it one more day
I'm so hungry we had a single meal a day
for lucky on the bad days
Kate brings me my food and eats it in
front of me he likes to touch himself
when I cry oh gosh this is so sad ah so
horrible what happened in this stupid
place why's everyone got to be a crazy
person Hey look another collectible good
for me oh no those batteries Oh knows a
collectible okay Cray right so good
dinner air too isn't up why is generator
2 not up okay all right okay all right
there was a little obstruction there I
actually restarted my game I resumed it
to see if I could get more bends oh and
I did it gave me like 14 pills I had to
slam down them all to be able to do this
so hopefully what that is gonna do
that's gonna give me enough of what I
need there was a little glowy there that
I didn't notice like those glowy's are
not very obvious but I assume that
something was going horribly wrong but
either way both generators are now up
this door is now open I can get out of
here okay is that grassland am I free am
i sha shake Redemption oh no right back
into it that was great okay that's cool
at least I'm a little more stable I'm
trying to move forward as quickly as
possible such that I'm able to not stay
in one place for too long
staying in one place means that I'm just
going to keep whoa I don't think this is
correct did the level not load here or
is that just supposed to be like that
okay-y well I fell good for me
now what do I do where am I okay yeah
sure
all right I'm like what the hell wait oh
oh wait it wasn't loaded or something
why is that black okay wasn't blackness
what the hell just happened I don't even
know if that was supposed to happen if
there's a burg I'd hate to think I'd
hate to think that this game it looks
why who's here who needs to be smashed
in the face cuz I am ready to smash
someone in the face might as well be you
okay
all right then let's see what else we
got
is everyone keeping an eye out because I
don't think that I'm in good company
here I think that some people might be
out to kill me well this looks familiar
it's definitely some place that I've
been before
yes looping back into old territory I
still don't know if I've seen any more
pills at any location man I want to keep
moving forward as quickly as both is
good so can't go into filing but not
going to management I'm sure some good
news are in management oh this is where
I heard them noises good why stop that
that is unnecessary you all got and now
my visions all warbly
it would be great if they would stop
doing that I hate the English yeah
now this dr. post is from London she
asks better than all of us hires all of
us Irish coffee and watching drink
that's the Irish way is what this is
what jacksepticeye's gonna be like in 10
years yeah she is just an angry old
Irishman 10 years I'll be awfully cruel
maybe like 30
I'll give him 30 I just want more pills
I haven't been able to keep enough down
man maybe that's the point of all this
it's gonna make me vomit boys oh man
it's just like being on a ship over and
over with the widow is that a real thing
that better not be a real thing summin
sort of SCP containment breach [ __ ]
where there's gonna be something
stopping around the background there's
that real it's real I just want some
more benzo give me more benzo
this is so sickening stop it Oh God okay
I don't know why that's suddenly happen
but that's a problem
I know problems and that was definitely
one so what is that but I can't see
anything now
or open pleaseplease path well I hope
that my vision will read oh I'm very
unwell visioned great finally Jesus I
don't know why that kept happening I
think it was just stuck in a loop where
for some reason I had stayed around in
one place too long and I wasn't able to
find any more bends oh I don't know if I
passed it or anything but I just was not
able to find it like it's gotta be like
some hidden away in some nook and cranny
good is that thing back I don't want
that thing to come find me I don't even
know what that thing was but it found me
before and that was a UH agreeable
occasion I don't think anything that's
not bends oh god damn it why is it sword
to find this crap you think that's such
an important tool they would give out
more freely even the guards here are
softer shite
except for the cowboy canes a mean old
bastard
oh I've heard so much about the great
and powerful King appropriate name - oh
it opens in who was opening the other
way before they need benzo Benz oh my
good buddy I'm gonna make sure I ration
you out oh oh this is not been by is
that a real thing I was one of the fakie
things yeah I don't know what this is
but maybe it's better maybe it's better
than but I think it is better than benzo
that fixed me right up gave me a good
number of it
okay so with that in my system now I'm
gonna be able to conquer this more
efficiently probably maybe not maybe
maybe not malece it'll be less
disorienting for you guys and for me I
was getting nauseous from that bowl have
I been here before I don't know it's
hard to tell where I've been okay so
this leads back to the cell block this
is where I'm at oh no this is different
okay this is not where I met the monster
I don't know where I met the monster
before but it wasn't a good occasion I
only hope that it doesn't happen again
so this leads no that's one of them bad
sounds it's one of them uh that's one of
them I'm gonna be murdered sounds I know
those sounds I've encountered those on
many occasion oh crap I'm on a diameter
diameter day I'm gonna die this day go
good it gives me plenty of room to
gallop I just need to get away from it
forever and ever and ever
can I shut this by me no okay I just got
to keep running great good for me this
looks like something that's bad open
open quickly open wisely shut bye
janab-i me shut it oh yeah you gonna do
nothing for that Oh turn around you
dickbag oh I have schooled you in the
ways of doors just for a double door
security ain't nobody gonna pass my door
we don't get that reloaded I needed a
better who is that more stuff Oh goddamn
it notes notes don't help my drug
problem
I think that thing might have been
supposed to be chasing me longer than it
gave me credit for but is it a
collectible
no okay there's got to be more benzo
around here somewhere I'm always on the
lookout just because I need it I think I
need one of these I don't know what this
other thing is unless it's like super
benzo Oh more stuff hey good luck that
wasn't a real thing god dammit how do I
know what's real what's not real oh boy
hey we making those noises
boy those boys Cheers
all right to the cargo bay I don't know
what that did but great good this is the
real thing okay on that way okay I think
that thing is after me but I don't much
appreciate it that thing is uh not
pleasant I think I got another note but
I haven't had a chance to stop and read
it oh this looks nice Oh what the hell
why is the elevator okay why don't just
do those noises without a reason being
there I open this no there's got to be
another way
I take another pill fix the liquid music
stop making those noises okay so I need
a five what the [ __ ]
all right then I guess everything's
changed now
good great okay here's all the pumps
where everyone slept tough craziness I
don't know if doors are gonna matter if
that thing can disappear ran how did I
get back here
I did not want to get back here I gotta
go down here I gotta find like I don't
know what device whoa okay I got an
elevator cover is that good is that what
I needed
why did I need that I don't know
I don't know what I need stop that
ah why is that thing don't come crawling
out for me you douche hmm either way I
got an elevator cover but I would assume
the L things change great this has been
a wild roller coaster of emotions here
there's no the battery there's another
note I don't have time to read notes I
got a thing on my ass
I like ease stop that
no please no I need to reload my be a
tree it's just making a lot of random
noises and I don't know if they mean
anything but my vision gets slightly
more disturbed so eat another pill I
took two just in case I'm gonna go down
here because down as good doubt is for
some reason very good okay
so this is the elevator I have a cover
it's gonna help
hey did Oh bye hi
okay bye I'm just gonna go upstairs I'm
a merry way out of here cuz you're all
sons of [ __ ]
great good let me not waste my
flashlight because apparently is a very
precious resource among other things but
I'm doing good I guess I don't know what
it wants for me I don't know what these
day ones this is duty run Lahey there's
that oh hey hi okay bye
Oh ghost Hollywood Tower Tarot put your
arms in the air own on the velvet arms
again I'm in the velvet arms of love I
do love being in the velvet arms of love
love I love love and I love you my boy
or you have found me my havens girls to
hide in it is my time but you must be
quick I'm drafted then find a better
place I can't see
so was that talking about the choices
again you see your enemy and striking
least explains it cousins rook to d5
check you're setting me up you talk when
all should be quiet to play oh this
looks fantastic but I want to take a
break from the insanity to read my notes
gonna be judged
someday for all the hurting I put on the
boys but that'll have to wait is that
the cowboy is that cane oh it's me okay
last night before I blew out the lamp I
got down on my knees and I prayed for
[ __ ] Mae
back in Missouri working at a school for
the underprivileged
she was good woman then I dreamt I was
back there tilling the fields and
singing songs ain't no goddamn songs
here none of the sweet choir of voices
no little angels just us demons never
shoot a shot that man of Kansas he was
stealing cattle from me so he had it
coming and no he was some relative a
former Governor Nixon who's only the
vice president now dumb luck I guess
wait have I how do I know if I've read
oh they're different sets okay well that
explains why it was harder to get
through everything okay don't trust what
you see this is the training this is the
brainwashing this isn't real while I was
pretty sure about that when the room
started moving all around me I was
pretty sure okay you've read all these
uh okay so there are different guards
there's the Irish guard and then there's
the cowboy guard Creed's oh that guy is
shot in the head that's the guy I saw
before I don't know if this is the guy
that had it coming to him stealing
cattle oh that guy has no eyeballs great
good great
hello I saw that come back here and get
your whoa you came back that I actually
didn't expect you just a marching fools
so oh hey let's go in there but no no
don't you look at me you weirdo
you think you're gonna get a big hug
you're gonna get a punch in the sack
that's what you're gonna yeah you better
run away you don't want no sack punching
it's Bad News Bears for you no don't
even try okay oh hey whoa uh I don't
have enough sack punching for you I have
a very limited amount of sack punching
available okay so I think I'm supposed
to avoid him but I'm such an expert at
this game that I did it without even
trying
don't know where I'm going now so you
are safe we shall end this Dawson
one will fall one of us one of you is
that you say you doc is that you that
cut open my spleen I didn't much
appreciate that by the by oh you can't
find me I'm like a shadow in that I just
stop oh this for me thank you thank you
were revolvers exactly what I needed
great I'll just ding-dong this button
here to floor for yes this game is weird
yeh I guess I don't know I don't know
anything anymore ah the welcoming sounds
of the asylum I can't wait to get back
into it but that's just gonna have to
wait until the next episode so thank you
everybody so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos that I've
done let me know what you're thinking of
its gaming down the description below
it's very mind messy that's what it is
it's not like perfect but it's got a lot
going for it so thank you again
everybody as always I will see you in
this
making weird noises oh you'll never beat
me haha I've got you now ah I'm the
flash whistling again huh oh hey buddy
how's it going now
nice nan bones you have there